hello and welcome
to special episode of spectator tv we're
going to be discussing the university's
crisis the impact of covert 19 and the
fate
of the sector in general i'm fraser
nelson i'm delighted to be joined by two
former university ministers joe johnson
and david willards is also the universe
the um the author of university
education thank you both for um for
joining me
um now joe you wrote for the spectator
fairly recently about the peril that you
thought would be facing british
universities the argument is a lot of
universities get there
and get their fees from overseas
students who are
far likely to be at university this year
but since then we've seen
a big increase in the number of british
people
applying for university and being given
offers due to the exams debacle
so where are we now do you think are
universities still
in a precarious financial situation well
we're waiting to find out fraser because
these are the critical days when we're
waiting to see
how many of those international students
who applied
actually turn up on campus and enroll
and go past the sort of the critical
moment of uh
of actually enrolling so this is all to
be decided in the
in the next all to be determined in the
next few days but you did make an
important point which is that
there is a big irony in this government
which
was seemingly trying to deter
young people from going to university in
in numbers
presiding over what has been the single
biggest increase
in enrollment rates of 18 year olds that
we've
seen probably at any single year since
the
robin's report in 1963 advocated
the expansion of higher education in the
uk we've seen an extraordinary
leap in the enrollment rate um two and a
half
percentage point jump this year versus
last year which is as far as i can see
the biggest we've seen in
in many many many years right now the
thing is
that um i'd like this to put this huge
little rule is that there's been a big
increase in people going to university
but a big decrease in the experience
they get when they get there
no freshers week but that's the least of
it it's more difficult to hang out in
groups and tutorials
and a lot of things are going online so
do you think that there is
a problem now that university students
who are under the reforms that you
support is paying up to 9 000 pounds a
year from this
not many of them are being given any
discount on that fee and yet they're
getting a fraction of what they
originally thought
they were buying um well and i just
on this as on many other issues i
suspect joe and i see it very
simply look it is a tough time to be
going to university because of all the
virus restrictions
but as with school and college the
government was right trying to encourage
people to go and
universities should be able to organize
higher education so you can have social
distancing and some real education
experiences
on what sort of financial support should
be offered
the fact is that these are not fees that
students pay up front so when i read all
this stuff in the media we should
somehow remit the fees what it means is
that down the track
someone 20 years on when they're in a
well-paid job will notice that their
repayments at nine percent of a higher
threshold
are finishing a couple of years earlier
than they otherwise would have done
which doesn't seem to me to be a massive
way of helping students now
so if there is any resource and
universities have got hardship funds
they should be doing things like
helping with rents making sure that
proper services including
things like food deliveries if students
are absolutely
being asked to isolate so practical help
now
not easing the pressures on well-paid
graduates in 20 years time
when it comes to practical helps did a
project not david
what about um allowing them to show up
to lectures what about making a bit more
effort
many workplaces now are doing what they
can to get as many people as possible
back into back into an office
environment universities seem to have
been
very uninterested in helping
i guess they've got a captive audience
young people who aren't truly going to
um go around the world now because you
wouldn't travel in the kobadi area
nor are they going to find a job when
unemployment is expected to double so
it seems as if the universities work out
so that young people don't have many
options
and they don't seem to have tried very
hard to continue
the university experience well i'm sure
the performance of universities varies
from from good to bad but look the
they're actually the government set out
four tiers of support and the the basic
model which is what i hope most
universities will get
most students may be that the
the large-scale lectures are online just
because getting 300 people into a
lecture theater is incredibly difficult
now
but there absolutely should be
face-to-face teaching
in smaller groups in seminars and
tutorials obviously for students in lab
based subjects they still need access to
labs which needs to be properly
organized
and so in my experience universities
have been
trying to continue to deliver real
education with physical contact as well
as online education
in what's called blended learning near
where i am at this moment down in the
university of portsmouth they've got a
walk-in
a testing center for students and you go
through that you get the results quickly
and then
there is a very strong education
environment in the university
right and johnson and you're a big
advocate of british universities but i
wonder if some of them will have
been harming their reputation by the way
that they have treated their students
during the coverage you've got some
universities who've said that they're
not going to have they've basically
cancelled online lectures
right up until the end of um well
until the end of the academic year so
everything's going online
irrespective of what happens with a
virus and i have to say that
the the market reforms that david willis
and others put in there were supposed to
make
students into the consumers they don't
feel like consumers
now well students do have
uh protection under consumer law and if
they feel
that they haven't received the kind of
education that they
contracted with their university to get
then there are
there is a course of action they can go
down they can first of all make a
complaint through their university then
to the
uh the adjudicator and then ultimately
you know they can take their complaint
um to the office for students um but i
think
you know on the whole phrase i think
these are pretty exceptional
um i think the sector has made heroic
efforts to adjust to the extraordinary
circumstances that the
virus is confronting it with and i do
generally think
that um the the sort of clamor for
uh refunds from the nus and ucu
on behalf of students is a bit misplaced
because
tuition fees you know pay for a huge
amount of
um of things which which which are
of vital importance within a university
they pay for
academic time they pay for the expertise
in teaching but they also pay for
mental health support cleaning and
maintenance administration
library the it and a hundred other
things so really
i think you would suddenly start
depriving a university of vital income
which they
which they actually need right now to
support students through this difficult
time they're also because of the need to
provide this hybrid form of learning
incurring additional costs which they
otherwise
wouldn't have so it's far from online
learning being a sort of a cut
price cheapskate way of providing higher
education it's actually
significantly more expensive than doing
traditional
face-to-face teaching if you think about
it distance learning involves
way more distance way more than just
recording a talk and
bunging it online it involves expensive
tech
it involves expensive tech support it
involves training academics how to use
it involves them getting it wrong first
time
re-recording it it involves them
adapting content to make it work to make
it accessible and richer
and then running the interactive
sessions themselves so it actually takes
far
more time for an academic to
prepare you know a two-hour seminar
than it does to deliver it in a
traditional face-to-face setting so
university costs are actually
blowing up as a result of this far from
far from the opposite and so they're in
they're not in a good position
to kind of absorb the demands for fee
reductions that
that we're hearing so much of at the
moment i can ask you joe johnson about
the office for
students this is a fairly new innovation
the idea here is it's a kind of a
quango which famously almost contains
toby young as its members but
not quite at the end and but they would
be the sort of the student's voice
um i'm wondering what role they play now
to the students who say for example that
not until they signed the lease for
their accommodation were they told
what exactly the um the online course
would learn so
they're feeling aggrieved that they've
had to stump up for university
accommodation
basically on a on a false premise
and it's not clear to me that the office
for students is in any position to help
them
well the office for students is a big
improvement on what went before in this
respect i mean previously we had a
higher education regulator
that very clearly was regulating in the
producer interest
the higher education funding council for
england as its name suggests
saw its principal role as to to funnel
as much money to providers
as it possibly could and the student
voice was was really not heard very
powerfully
in hefki um i think you know under
under michael barber and nicola
dandridge the office for students is
putting the student
at the forefront of its thinking and
they've been leading the way
for example in developing ideas around
student contracts
in ensuring that students are
represented fully in panels that are
meant to assess the quality of teaching
and student outcomes
and in ensuring that universities are
clear with students about
exactly what they can expect at the time
that they
that they apply and and enroll of course
there's always you know room to go
further and i think there is a difficult
balancing act that the office for
students has to
has to strike in a crisis such as this
when it when it needs also to think
about sustainability of the higher
education system as a whole
but i think by and large the office of
students is a is in much needed reform
it was inspired by
david's white paper way back in 2011-12
i think it was called students at the
heart of the system is that what it was
called
yup yup and you know that set that set
the
sort of the the theory for why you
needed
um to make sure the student voice was
more prominent in our
regulation of higher education and i
think the office for students is is on a
journey
to making that a reality so david will
it's
let's go with that theme students at the
the heart of the system
um in what way are they at the heart of
the system
now and what way have we seen um
students
um or consumer demand the power and
talks about the power it has the power
shifted from the providers to the users
of higher education
in a meaningful way or are they just
paying a lot more money for something
they would have probably got anyway
well i did see the reforms that i
brought in and joe brought in as well
like the ofs as kind of bringing in the
new world to redress the balance in the
old i actually
saw strengthening the power of students
as
if anything driving universities focus
more on a high quality academic
experience because when you actually
spoke to students
they weren't plotting marxist revolution
they were complaining they didn't get
their essays back in time
um and they didn't see enough of the
people who were doing the lectures
uh now those were the kind of
preoccupations and i think they still
are their preoccupations as to whether
we've made any progress
i think in the last 10 years we have and
it's taken several forms first of all
because we were also able to get rid of
number controls because we no longer had
the old style model when it was a lot of
public expansion the treasury controlled
it by
controlling student numbers universities
compete for students
they compete for students on the offer
that they make and also
on the quality of the academic
experience
and because universities can expand if
more universe students want to go there
more students are getting their first
choice of university so that's the first
clear piece of evidence secondly
although it is incredibly hard to
measure teaching standards in
universities because there isn't a
single exam
and a starting exam and a finishing exam
like you have in the school system
i do buy the evidence that is coming in
that if anything the focus on the
academic standards
and the quality of teaching has improved
in the last 10 years
and joe's reforms played an important
part
in that because when i started back in
2010
you had this paradox of an intensely
competitive regime for research funding
which was driving british
university-based research to absolutely
the top of the
global lead table and no competition for
students you just collected the dollop
of money from the treasury and had a
limit on the number of students you
could take
so my view was that we if anything we
were hyper competitive on research we
needed to promote a bit more
collaboration
but when it came to teaching we needed
good old-fashioned competition to
try to drive an increased focus on
teaching and universities are much more
focused on teaching than they were
right but i'm wondering i mean i'll give
you an example joe johnson something
that happened recently that made me
really wonder
and what's where the power lay the
universities
they were worried about kobits and they
asked the government to basically put a
cap
on places i took that to mean that the
the less popular universities were
worried but the more popular
universities were going to expand their
places there were going to be more
places and russell group universities so
the best universities would have more
people
that would leave less pure people for
the lower tier
universities now the government went
along with this saying it provided more
stability for the university sector
but in what way was this really in the
interests of students because surely
something like that could only be
intended
to deprive students of getting the extra
opportunities at the top
universities that were about to be
created because they feared there were
fewer international students i mean to
me
this is this was a straightforward
almost conspiracy against students
in the interest of the of the sector
collectively
the short-lived return of student number
controls in the way you described
effectively did for a time
constrain the role that student choice
plays in determining
the size and shape of the sector and i'm
glad that
the short it was a short-lived uh
experiment and that and that thankfully
um the number controls were removed
again pretty
pretty rapidly um you know i think that
you can see why government acceded to
the sector's request
that they return in in circumstances we
found ourselves in
namely that you know some some
universities feared there would be a
scramble for
for for students and that students
regardless of the quality of their
products the universities regardless of
the quality of their provision
might find themselves in in extreme
financial difficulties
and and and risk disorderly failure
and that would be an undesirable
situation for
students themselves at that institution
and for the system and reputation
of uk higher education as a whole so you
can see why government
was tempted to restore student number
controls for a bit
i'm very glad that in reality uh
international student
applications were such that the
government felt able to
to lift those number controls again and
we've now got you know student choice
playing its full role
um in how the in the size and shape of
the sector
from from next year onwards i think
that's that's that's a good thing
um so this the sector can continue to
respond to
to competition to you know the signals
that
that um that's the universities are
sending out about where high quality
teaching and research are and can be
found
fraser can i add one comment on that i
mean i've agreed to what joe said but
also to come back to your reference to
lower tier universities and all that um
a problem which we're all complicit in
is if when we say leading universities
top universities higher tier
universities
the most powerful single evidence we are
thinking of is research quality and
research performance
that's uh and on that we can measure
whether you are kind of getting
published in the most prestigious
international journals and we can see
the universities that are every time we
rank universities solely on the measure
of research
we are rewarding behavior in which
universities focus
on their effort on research rather than
on teaching and it reaches the point
where if you were trying to look at this
from a narrow economic perspective it is
rational for an individual student to
settle
for not having much teaching knowing
that their react the resource they bring
in is going on research if that pushes
the university up the research rankings
which everything means every intern
values their degree more highly so if we
all in day-to-day media comment
play up the model the only ranking of
universities is research performance we
make the problem that you worry about
worse because we and the and joe's tef
was an in uh
anything that enables us also to remind
people that there are less prestigious
universities that may also be doing well
on teaching and that teaching matters
helps tackle the problem you're rightly
worried about
but isn't this i mean sure we talk about
same higher tier in the words here
and you're right there are university
ranking systems and there's a
whole lot more to what an undergraduate
gets from university
than simply and how the university is
ranked in research
but if you also look at the most popular
universities and the least popular the
ones that charge
the full nine thousand pounds the ones
that charge less there is a broad
overlap and it wasn't the whole purpose
of your market reforms but the most
popular universities would be allowed to
expand and that less popular
universities
would not and to put it this way some of
them might actually go bust
because if they were doing courses that
weren't really serving students or
society in words in demand
then they ought to be allowed to go bust
because that is what the market does
correct that is the logic of the system
uh and absolutely when
the student choice matters and
i began a process and joe took a lot
further getting more information
out there for prospective students
including
in so far as it could be measured uh
teaching quality
measured through student satisfaction
more in more empirical measures
as well so yeah i wanted the student
choice to
drive the system of teaching but equally
i want the student
choice to be informed by evidence and
views on teaching not just
on research and my frustration
with the system we've got is we've still
got the back of everyone's head a kind
of
ranking of a good university versus a
bad university
which is heavily shaped by research
performance not teaching performance
right now joe johnson um we haven't
it's funny that the when the
universities do say less the less
popular ones however you want to
describe it
when there is concern that they are
going to come under financial pressure
this is always tends to be seen now as a
bad thing
but why should that be so why shouldn't
it be the case
that the most popular universities
expand the number of places because when
they
uh when david willis et al made their
reforms
it wasn't just the introduction of fees
it was the lifting of the cap
the lifting of the cap was a really
fundamental change
and this is one of the reasons correctly
if i'm wrong that we see a lot more
students from poorer backgrounds going
to university
nowadays i mean no the sector has
expanded
very significantly fraser since uh the
student number controls were lifted
progressively from 2013
onwards and um that that shows up in the
in the increased enrollment rate of 18
year olds and 19 year olds in particular
um you know many many more young people
are going to university as a result of
the expansion
of universities and you know some some
of them have have almost doubled in size
i mean the likes of bristol and exeter
they're almost unrecognizable some some
universities have grown so much they've
kind of swallowed the towns around them
um so you know the sector certainly has
expanded
your question is why don't we let
universities fail
when they fail the test of the market
and cease to cease to
see demand for their courses well
occasionally you do see consolidations
of institutions and you see closure of
programs and closure of courses
it happens that this has been a very
strong period of growth
in higher education over the last uh
eight or nine years
and you know institutions by and large
haven't been under extreme
financial stress but i think
philosophically both
david and i recognize that there might
be circumstances
in which a university would want to
merge or consolidate
be consolidated with it with another um
close a program and personally i was
always
um fairly sanguine about that prospect
i rec i i thought the sector couldn't be
preserved in aspect
and never had been you know we have
about 160 universities in the country at
the moment this is a new phenomenon you
know for several hundred years there was
just oxford and cambridge in england and
andrews and so on in scotland
the sector has grown and and expanded
um and there have been murders and
consolidations along the way
as as the sector has expanded so i
didn't see preserving it in aspect as
part of the
duties of government i thought we needed
to facilitate
an environment in which student choice
could could
shape um the sector and and allow
students to gravitate towards where they
felt they were going to get the best
outcomes for themselves
right sorry phrase again sorry if i may
add two comments to joe's observations
first
i was working for mrs t in the mid-80s
when she was at the height of her powers
in the policy unit
and in 1986 a
university college in cardiff went bust
and was due to close ken baker the
education
secretary came around and persuaded mrs
t
that the university college had to be
rescued and a merger
was organized so the politics of
of literally padlocks at the gates
tumbleweed blowing across the campus
we're weeping students outside because
the whole thing is closed down
um was qui has always been quite tricky
where i think
the the what is missing from the debate
so far i think if you tried to take the
market model and we're talking this is
not like a proper
uh completely free market but there's
clearly uh competition and we're talking
about a version of bankruptcy
takeover also matters and one of my
frustrations is that our higher
education system
is still a closed system there are big
international chains
none of them sadly british but there are
big university chains
indian-based american-based
spanish-based
chinese-based they would love to buy
an english higher education institution
so as well as the assumption that they
just close in some close
in some closed system model
there is an international market out
there and another challenge i think one
of the issues over the next few years
is whether overseas investors will be
allowed in some way to take these over
and turn them around
right but i suppose it's funny joe
johnson and some of you
let's take the ivy league now um
stanford university i remember recently
he was
issued something like a um a hundred
year bond here was an institution
so financially secure but it was able to
raise his own money
by borrowing quite a low interest rate
for the market because nobody
could imagine any circumstances in the
next hundred years
where stanford university could be in
any serious amount of financial trouble
such as the
confidence in the financial prospects of
a world beating
university now britain probably has more
world-beating universities per capita
than any other country
in the world if you look at how many top
50 universities we've got
i forget is something like um about a
dozen or something where no eurozone
country
is even got one so yes we do very well
in it the conservatives are tended to be
the party
that have done their best to help the
higher education sector grow but i
wonder if covid
has shown a pretty big challenge to that
that
if you get um this is a black swan event
where all of a sudden
we can't rely on people coming from
overseas in as many numbers
to universities and we're already
beginning to see already this
conservative government
has dropped the the demands to get or
the target
to get 50 of young people into
university so i wonder
if if we're so sure really that
the tides that the future will
necessarily
involve more money and more business to
universities or whether it might have
seemed that way
five or six years ago but things look
different now especially
after the virus struck well
i mean you're right this has been a real
test of the
model for for our university's finances
um many institutions have have become
very dependent on
international student fee income
to put on high cost courses
that this fee income plays a big part in
several
cross subsidies in our model the subsidy
primarily is to research a significant
amount of
funding from international students goes
straight into our
science system and that's why
there would be real damage to our
capabilities as an r d nation if we
decided we didn't if we decided to or if
we or if we saw a sustained
a fall off in in international student
numbers but there's also a subsidy into
um high cost courses whether they're lab
based or
studio based which which affects um the
the courses that are available to
domestic students so
it's like having a hub airport in the
sense that the
the fact that we've got international
students coming in
makes it possible for universities to
offer courses that would otherwise be
loss-making and therefore
they increase the choice available to
our domestic student population
so this model is under stress um
i i personally think this is
you know it's the international students
play a play a vital part
um in sustaining the richness of our
university environment
they not only do those two things that i
mentioned
increasing the choice available to
domestic students and putting more money
than we otherwise would
into our science base but they also
enable our students to study in a
diverse environment and i i really think
we sometimes
underestimate and how crucial that is
i often hear you know people say well
you know why do we have so many chinese
students in our universities
and you know isn't isn't there a lack of
diversity on campus
i think we're getting this the wrong way
around we should genuinely celebrate
the fact that chinese students want to
come and study here because
boy are we going to need to understand
china
and the world view of chinese people in
years to come
and in five ten years time when the
chinese higher education system has
developed even more than it has already
we may not see these flows in such
numbers as we do today
and i think we will we will regret
quibbling over the numbers of chinese
students that we now
benefit from and see on our campuses and
ditto
the numbers of indian students and
students from from other countries
around the world
it's a real privilege for our young
people to be able to study
in this diverse environment and to learn
from people
and their different perspectives on on
our global challenges and i think that's
a critical message which we all need to
understand
okay um david will it's uh sometimes
it's said that if you compare
a british degree to an ivy league one
but nine thousand pounds a year is
really quite cheap
the yeah take for example somebody who
went to
went to an expensive private school they
went to watford to cambridge
and they could be paying 25 30 000
pounds a year
for the private school yet they only are
paying 9 000 pounds for their
oxbridge or cambridge course even if it
costs actually a lot more to run
now why should somebody like that is
argued be subsidized
is there the potential to increase the
fees
further at least for families who can
afford it
and maybe we ought to be looking at the
way the americans do
about just simply allowing about
liberalizing or lifting the controls on
what universities charge
to allow them to um
to be better financed so what are your
thoughts about that in the future
of a 9 000 a year cap now that you're
out of the house of commons you can
perhaps
tell us what you really think
uh i always try to say what i really
thought though
they're always with under certain
constraints yeah um
the trouble of course those kind of
options are looked at um
there are i think the means test
and you're saying well should sort of
rich students pay more
the best way you can operate the means
test is through the graduate repayment
system where essentially
people who end up in well-paid jobs pay
back a lot and if for whatever reason
you're not in a well-paid job you don't
pay back so much so we
we have got a kind of means test in the
system at the i think at the right point
um we don't we have looked at options of
allowing some universities to charge
even higher fees
and oxford in cambridge certainly could
and
have pressed for that freedom the
difficulty
is that you'd actually have a kind of
reverse pupil premium effect you would
find that the resources going into
the most prestigious universities
where also i have to say also socially
the most selective those would go up
and you'd have a further problem at the
at the other end of the system
so there was it was hard to work out an
actual
practical way in which you could do this
in a way that was equitable
and you'd have ended up having to
having to put more public money in at
the at the other end probably
the universities that take more kids
from poor backgrounds take more kids
from
black and minority ethnic groups all
those type of challenges the lower tier
as you call them
they're actually often taking on
students who if they were secondary
schools would enable them to get extra
resources with the pupil premium
and you did you find it depressing david
willis after
that after you liberalized the reforms
universities became a lot more
commercial
it wasn't that long before we saw that
the pay of those rights at the top of
the university hierarchy go up
quite a lot we started to see sort of
reserves
of cash being built up it started to
look
um pretty early on as if um this was
leading to the
transfer of resources to a new
and better paid administrative class
of universities well there was some of
that and it got uh and it caused a lot
of controversy understandably
um especially if the procedures and the
governance weren't right i mean in other
words if it didn't look as if these were
paid decisions being taken properly
independently
um of the people involved so yeah there
was a hard feeling about it
i have to say in general though my
experience was that the
the money from the fees did go into
uh services for students and and just to
go through the gory details because
of say capital spending and we've had
the prime minister
today and i think it's great announcing
more public expense on capital
for fe colleges there used to be a
public
capital budget for universities for
teaching facilities
a tiny bit of it survives we got rid of
most of it as part of the cuts in 2010
and i can still remember the
conversation to the treasury
because i said look universities do need
to build new stuff and they said right
now they're going to have this income
from fees they can use it to service the
debt as they
undertake commercial borrowing we're
shifting from public money
funding capital to using their income
from fees to service the borrowing so
that they can have capital expansion
um we had a lot of programs to help
disadvantaged students which in have now
become
a claim on the 9k fees so a lot of the
money went in that way
much more went that way than on vice
chancellor's pay
right um now we're also going to take
questions from those
watching us as well i've got a question
here
um from from james um to you joe johnson
how do you see our indications of how
covid is going to affect students grades
can we see any grade
inflation uh i did um see somewhere i
think it was magdlin college in oxford
that was increasing the proportion of
of people who had firsts to a quite
alarming degree
well there is there is i think first of
all before we get to the issue of great
inflation i think we're going to
see a real risk of an inflation in the
rate at which
students drop out and that's my actually
bigger concern right now
interesting well you know
the transition from school to university
is is a is a is a big one it's a there's
a big gap
in the style of learning the pace of
learning and for many people
particularly
for kids from disadvantaged backgrounds
that gap is already a challenge
in the context of the difficult learning
environment of the last six months
in secondary schools that gap is going
to be bigger than ever
and i think the real focus and that the
office for students and the sector as a
whole
needs to have right now is on those
students starting their first year
when they're going to feel overwhelmed
by many pressures
right now and i feel all
very significant focus needs to be made
needs to be given to pastoral support
to teaching support and learning support
so that those students don't drop out
across the system in a normal year
fraser you see about six
to six or seven percent of students drop
out and normally that's at the end of
the first term or at some point
in the first year um i i worry very much
that this number will be significantly
higher
this year first of all because we've
seen a very significant increase
as i mentioned earlier in the proportion
of people
uh entering higher education and and
that increase has principally
come or to a very significant extent
come from
uh pupils from disadvantaged backgrounds
from families
without a traditional history of sending
young people to
their young people to university and
second because of the extraordinary
environment
um that that we're now in over the last
six months so for me
yes degree inflation is a real problem
and the sect has been terribly remiss
in not getting to grips with it and
letting it run out of control and
letting it
devalue the currency of an english
higher education qualification and it's
a huge regret that that's happened
but i don't think that's as big a policy
priority as dealing with the risk of
non-continuation or dropouts
okay and we've got a question now from
from david to you david willits and to
what extent has the expansion of student
numbers diminish the value
of normal standard first degrees
in the eyes of employers i guess this is
this is quite
an old and quite familiar question but
certainly you know
when i was young and it was i was the
first member of my family ever to go to
university and then
it was to actually have it was very rare
in those days
and it's a lot less rare now we've got a
lot more people with degrees and and
nobody would deny this is a far better
thing than having only a few
only the richest seven percent 10 of
students with degrees
but isn't it an undeniable quarterly of
that
that to have a degree no longer quite
sets you apart as it once did
so it's harder to say as i think your
government did at the time
if you get a degree you're likely to
earn x amount more than you would
if you didn't have a degree simply
because the more you increase the number
of people with degrees
the less value employers are going to
place in those degrees and all of a
sudden the difference between a graduate
and a non-graduate or somebody did an
apprenticeship becomes
far more blurred than it would have been
before the expansion of
student numbers started to take place um
seven or eight years ago well
there is some of the phenomena you
described i mean it's it's one of many
drivers in the system but look
throughout the growth you say in the
last seven or eight years
if you take the long trend back in the
days of robbins it was five percent
we're now on about 50 percent and at
every stage of that process
people have raised your concern you know
there's the graduate premium is going to
diminish what's the point of getting to
university
uh there should be a restraint on this
growth but i think in
overall the extraordinary phenomenon is
how the graduate premium has held up
despite this massive growth now it does
look as if in the last few years
there's been if anything a slight
diminution
of that graduate premium but it's still
there and we don't know to what extent
that's
uh uh just shaped by the poor
performance of the labor market overall
since the crash of 2008 nine in indeed
the work we've done at resolution
foundation and elsewhere suggestive
anything what's happened there was an
increase in unemployment post that crash
and non-graduates tended to be
unemployed graduates traded down into
some non-graduate jobs so they did
better on employment but indeed
graduate earnings on average uh didn't
do quite so well but they're still way
ahead of non-grads
so i'm i still think there's an
underlying trend for advanced economies
by and large
to need people with more years of
education
i see that as a trend over the last 150
years as a trend in other advanced
western countries
and as we saw this summer trying to be
king canute
holding back that surge of young people
into
education including higher education is
a very uncomfortable position
to be in all right on the on that note
here's a question from sophie to you joe
johnson
and is there a concern that the exam's
debacle whereby a lot of people
were given the exams that they were
predicted and we saw a huge increase in
the number of a's
and b's given versus last year we mean a
lot of people have been given places at
university who will struggle
to cope and this comes back to your
point about dropout so the dropout will
happen
simply because the government in a panic
has allocated a lot of university places
to people who would struggle to cope
academically
at the pace in which they're now going
to learn and that's
as you put said that the government's
short-term fix could
quickly turn into a longer-term problem
well i think there is a certainly a risk
of
as i said students dropping out in
higher than usual numbers this year and
that that
that phenomenon the question describes
is
it may may play a part in it um if
students are being admitted into courses
which they may struggle on
and i think that puts the real onus on
on uh on the sector to
to take responsibility for students once
you know universities take great pride
in being
autonomous in their admissions it's one
of the sort of the tenets of our system
that government doesn't interfere in in
university admissions
but if you claim that autonomy you've
got to take the responsibility
that comes with it and i think that
means that when you admit a student
you've then got to ensure they don't
drop out and that you provide them with
the support
at every stage in their journey through
to graduation and beyond
so i think universities really have to
really step up now
and take responsibility they've they've
admitted students in large numbers and
they need to
make sure that they get through their
courses okay
and here's a question from edwards to
you and
david willis will the move to virtual
learning and
first of all diminish the opportunities
for networking at university
and therefore secondly social mobility
and i guess that the idea is at
university you might come from
from a poor background you might come
from what we call the pool or five areas
least likely to send people to
university
but you would mix you go to clubs and
societies you would mix with people
on uh like-minded people and you you'd
be able to so do social mobility through
campus
if there isn't the same mixing due to
covid and people
are being cooped up in their rooms is
the social mobility aspect likely to be
hit
by the restrictions the universities are
now imposing
yeah i do worry about that um i think
it's not a unique problem in
universities i think it's
um it's a wider problem and in fact you
know joe
fraser myself we'll probably all have a
similar experience at
our stage of careers when you go you
used to do events and give a talk or
give a lecture and some keen young
people would come up afterwards and ask
you some questions and
you'd try to give them some advice i
think the moment when you press the
leave the meeting button
at the end of the presentation without
that extra five or ten minutes
afterwards for
the people often younger people to come
and talk to is a real loss
and there's a similar phenomenon in
higher education so it is a risk it's
absolutely true it's a risk
i think that's probably one of the
reasons why universities were so keen if
at all possible at least to get people
onto campus even if the lecture was
online that was being attempts to
in a socially distanced environment
provide opportunities for students still
to mix that's why they want that to
happen
and also there's some really smart work
going on by experts in the digital
economy
ways in which you can create virtual
equivalence
of those informal uh arrangements
you know including sort of random
lotteries whereby you link up people in
this
in the same institution the same
university the same department who might
have had a gossip in the queue at
the coffee machine and instead find
themselves randomly linked up
so yes it is a problem and through a
maintaining campus environment and
digital innovation i hope it can be
overcome
okay and joe johnson another question
here
do you think that if universities have
learnt the art of beaming their lectures
now to people
in their student halls the same
technology you could beam these lectures
and learning experience to students
right around the world
and now these these foreign students
that you mentioned they could be given a
sort of quasi
open university experience because
universities if they're doing their job
properly will be learning the tools
of how to replicate that as much as they
can digitally so might this
turn out to be not the calamity for
education higher education
that you envisage but a massive
technological revolution
and a genuine opportunity to go global
yeah that's a very interesting
uh way of thinking about it and of
course that's right technology does
expand the market for
our world-class higher education
significantly
and universities will be able to tap
into segments of populations that
don't want the full fat three to four
year
courses or one to two year masters
courses overseas in another country
and they will be able to slice and dice
courses to to appeal to those
those income segments below those that
have traditionally taken advantage of
opportunities to study overseas
um so i think that is that is that
certainly is an opportunity but
i don't think it will uh displace
the traditional uh
model of international higher education
that britain
canada the us australia and new zealand
um
have have dominated over the last
few decades i think there will always be
a demand
for traditional face-to-face fully
immersive
experience overseas because higher
education is a bundle of things it's not
just
the teaching it's the network it's the
labor market opportunities
either in the study destination country
or what studying overseas adds to your
qualifications when you return to your
home
country and for many people it's that
bundle
of things the networking the labor
market experience
the living overseas the language
acquisition
that are actually just as important as
the pedagogical content of any course
which as you say can to some greater
degree or other
can now be delivered by other means
remotely or online or virtually or
whatever
so i do think you know i certainly see
it in a positive frame
that this expands the market for our
world-class higher education and our
most astute
institutions are taking full advantage
of that
thank you any other questions do you
send them through on the um
on the chat function in zoom and another
question
from edwards to you and david willetts
um can you
comment on the value of university
alternatives such as apprenticeships
and because over the last few years you
now quite often
see very prestigious and secondary
schools as
you know very expensive ones they will
announce not only are they got x many
kids to you know bristol to durham to
oxford to cambridge
but they might also say by the way we've
got two students on an apprenticeship
for jaguar land rover or something like
that they seem to be as proud as that of
that
as they are of getting into the
universities in the old days so
it seems that apprenticeships are being
certainly seen
to be as glittering a prize as a place
as some of the best universities yeah i
mean i think an apprenticeship at jaguar
land rover is a fantastic thing to do
so good for great for people who get it
the the issue i don't think is the
prestige
of apprenticeships it's when you think
of apprenticeships like that
the supply is quite limited an
apprenticeship is an actual employer
wishing to employ a young person then
invest in their education and training
and it's and i think it's no accident
you think of
of uh convention not conventional but
established manufacturing firms we
that's the kind of environment where we
think of the apprenticeship
they're great but they just aren't going
to get the volume
that is required unless we massively
changed our labor market
it's no accident that high education
participation is particularly high
in liberal market economies with
relatively unregulated labor markets
if you go down the german route with
many more protected activities
many more licenses to practice that you
need to secure
through an apprenticeship and you can't
do this job unless you've done an
apprenticeship and reach the following
requirement
you can't call yourself an electrician
or whatever then
you you reverse a lot of our labor
market changes
and you can create an environment where
there are many more protected jobs and
apprenticeships so my view has always
been that it
it's not anyone is against
apprenticeships throughout my adult
political career successive governments
have announced incredibly ambitious
targets for them
but you just don't have the number of
employers and the number of protected
careers where an apprenticeship is a
pre-re it's a prior requirement
to be able to match germany's volume
okay
now johnson it's you're talking there
about how you like to see universities
do more
in the pastoral care of students
especially those in deprived backgrounds
who might otherwise be dropping out
we we do hear quite a lot from
government increasingly for what they
would like universities to do
and as government provides a lot of the
financial support governments in a
pretty decent position to call these
shots
i wonder also to be pressured
universities
to open up if they've got again i mean
earlier on we spoke about sharing online
lessons in them in the context of
international students but you could
also
make it more accessible for domestic
students
so people who would quite like to to
learn or at least to see
what it is like to see um a history
lecture at oxford or
or the zoology lecture at bristol you
know you could actually say to them we
would like you to do more to make these
openly
accessible if you're going to be
recording these things why have them in
a closed circuit to your students
why not let them be shared more openly
and therefore and promote greater
equality of access if not to the degree
than at least
to the educational experience no i think
there's a there's a lot to that and i
think one of the
silver linings of the corona virus was
the energy that the department for
education put into
making available uh online resources
that that previously weren't
so you know bbc played its part uh
many universities um and and
education providers of one form or other
collaborated in making content available
that that that otherwise wouldn't have
been
that was pretty rupee content wasn't it
i mean we knew that for example
a lot of the private schools um went
digital
a lot of those private schools could
have been sharing their lessons because
it's for exactly the same curriculum for
the same gcses for the same a levels
but they didn't they kept to all closed
circuits and if you wanted to go online
sure
what you got in the bbc was better than
nothing but there still seems to be this
idea that yes we've got the tech
to send it to a small number of people
but we choose not to send it to more
people
even though we could so the technical
opportunity
of expanding the availability of these
incredibly precious resource
the principles that founded the open
university
seem not to be there and i'm wondering
if they need to be given a little bit of
a nudge
by government to widen to share a bit
more yeah
i mean i think it is it's a very
interesting um
question as to why publicly funded
higher education providers don't make
more of their content
generally available now that technology
enables them
to do so and there is a sort of
effective fetishization
of selectivity in our system and i guess
the fear is that
once content becomes available to a mass
audience
that sort of that sort of aura of
selectivity
will be diminished and i think that
would be that's
perhaps part of of why universities
don't share
um as much of their content as as they
might on the other hand i think
everyone is relatively new to this
business i think many universities will
probably be open to it
over time once they've mastered all of
the arts of of curating online content
and maintaining it and worked out a way
of
paying for for very expensively curated
and maintained online content
i i don't i don't think this is a
question of
of goodwill in the long run um if if
they can find a way of
funding a way of keeping it at keeping
it available and maintained
um to be more broadly accessed in the
future
and joe in your spectator article you
were talking about the potential
seven billion hits to the sector that
wasn't your figure you quoted somebody
else who calculated it
and are you now and your right is all up
in the air now but i take it you're
feeling a lot less pessimistic
given that we've seen the young people
have got so few options that they're
going to university anyway and then
this made me prove i mean the funny
thing is that you and me might think
and that if they're locked up in their
holes this might diminish the
appetite for university but it doesn't
seem to so it seems that the
universities might ride out the storm
after all
yeah no i i think it's far that seven
billion figure was a number that
university uk put out
as a sort of a scare figure in early
discussions with the treasury and it
didn't scare the treasury very much the
treasury said come back later when we
know what the situation is
which was the appropriate response in
hindsight
it didn't look as though they were
playing rather hard ball at the time but
in in hindsight the treasury
called it absolutely right we don't yet
know though however as i said how many
international students are actually
going to enroll
right now and that will still determine
the financial position of
of of a few universities at the margin
but the situation is infinitely better
than it than it appeared back in march
partly as you say because domestic
enrollments have been
so strong this year because of the
exams uh the exam
the situation and the way universities
were compelled to admit everybody to
whom they made offers
okay um david will it's a question for
you and what was your biggest mistake
using as university's minister i don't
think you're getting out of this joe
we're going to come back to you but
david first
what was your biggest mistake come on
you guys are both out of practice
nobody's going to be voting for you
again
you can you can tell us right there i
i'll give
i'll offer you two mistakes i'm sure
there are many more as well let me
spring to mine first of all saying early
on
that uh there would be price competition
when you think about it given it's a
graduate repayment system where the
students are not paying upfront
a student who had said um i would have
gone to
york but it was 8750 and i was
deciding instead to go to leeds because
it was 7500
um would have been acting in a very
peculiar way because they weren't
actually having to write a check for an
extra 1250 it's all a graduate repayment
scheme so suggesting there would be
price competition in that way was a
mistake i wanted competition for
students and i wanted an open system
but it was wasn't going to be price
competition i think that was a mistake
and the second thing that i
regret where things just didn't play out
as i expected was the decline in the
number of adult learners i mean we
actually extended loans to adult
learners hoping that they would take
them up
and many fewer took them up than we
expected
so for that reason and other reasons big
decline in public sector
opportunities for people to train up we
had a decline in the number of mature
students
and uh oddly enough i think one of the
things boris is after in his
announcement today is to
try to get people to think of university
as not just an
experience for an 18 or 19 year old who
instantly are the people who are likely
to want the physical experience of
leaving home and going to a campus
it's also an opportunity for people
through their adult lives
when the opportunity of online learning
and the digital revolution may be much
more relevant
so i would have those are my two
mistakes to start off with
well they're very interesting especially
i guess and it was said initially that
the was going to be a range a cap of up
doing a capital nine thousand pounds
so technically you could envisage it at
the time some people saying eight or
seven or six or five
your point is that to the students
that's much of a muchness because
earlier on we were discussing whether
students should receive a refund
and you were saying that well what's the
point in that because the refund would
just be
paying back a tiny little bit less in
about 20 years time
so i see how the the range in prices
didn't work out in the way that you
thought
but similarly i guess that means you
also didn't work out the extent to which
so many
of them would just go straight to the
full 9000
immediately well we had uh
an expectation that what we thought and
this is now ancient history but
what we thought was that there would be
two bunches that we had there was a sort
of differential
regulatory regime above six thousand we
thought some universities would so you
weren't going to get competition on the
last 500 or thousand
we thought it might be worthwhile a
university saying
come to us for five thousand seven
hundred and fifty we thought at that
point
even though it's still a graduate
repayment scheme people would see that
as a shorter
a significantly shorter period of
repayments so i
we ended up expecting that and one or
two universities tried
i think coventry tried it um but what
did surprise me is that
that not that didn't attract a group of
students either when
we thought we would but you know this is
this is
student this is student choice and uh
and
good for them and it the lesson i
learned from all this is it's very hard
to prescribe what students
will want to do and there's just a
hunger out there for higher education
and um the appetite keeps on growing
well we've given dude johnson a long
time to think of his answer to this
question so go on jeremy
the confessional is open what was your
greatest mistake as you and then
in the many times you served as
university minister i mean
apart from when i launched a
competition for the public naming of a
polar research vessel
without without knowing what the answer
would be in advance
um and it got given beauty mcboatface
now apart from that and apart from uh
somehow being persuaded that it would be
a good idea to appoint someone to
the board of the ofs um
someone searching close to the pages of
the spectation magazine is that right
apart from apart from those two things
who tried to persuade you
elder brother i think no no no no no
apart from my biggest
apart from those things my biggest
mistake um i think was probably not
pushing
hard enough to be honest to get rid of a
very
technical rule that's been an absolute
disaster
which is the so-called equivalent or
lower qualification
rule now phrase this is so arcane you
may not know what it is
but this is an insane rule that says if
you're an
adult you can't take a qualification
if it's equivalent or lower to one you
already possess
and this has been the bane of our
efforts to reskill and enable adults to
retrain and reskill
during their working lives because if
they've already done a particular degree
they can't do another one at an
equivalent or a lower qualification
now we made a tiny bit of progress when
we got it lifted with respect
to equivalent or lower qualifications in
stem subjects
which was progress but it's still in
place
generally and it's one of the reasons
why as david mentioned
we've seen such a catastrophic fall in
the
numbers of people undertaking part-time
courses in this country because many of
the people taking these part-time
courses
are adult learners and they can't do it
at an equivalent or lower level
than they presently have and we've got
to get rid of it okay important point i
i thought for a moment joe you were
going to say that your mistake was
deciding to stand down as a politician
because think of the fun you could be
having
do you ever turn on the tv and think
actually i i could be in that
chamber i wonder if i made the right
choice um well look you've got to
live life looking forward and no no
regrets
no regret well on that note let us all
reach for the leave meeting button that
david said is rather depressing to click
it's been
great to have you with joe johnson david
willis thanks very much indeed
and thanks for watching and now let's
all click
red button leave